Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est le premier avril, c'est une date très spéciale parce que ça signifie que ça fait trois mois tout pile que je fais des vidéos,
et que vous en avez une par jour depuis le premier janvier.
Au départ mon défi, c'est de faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
j'ai rempli un quart du défi.
Le premier avril, c'est surtout le jour du poisson d'avril !
C'est le jour de la blague.
Aujourd'hui je devais mentaliser quelqu'un et je me suis ravisé. Je vais vous donné les 6 clés pour réussir un bon poisson d'avril.
Même si vous voyez cette vidéo à 17H, il n'est jamais trop tard pour faire un poisson d'avril.
Techniquement avec le fuseau horaire, vous pouvez encore faire votre poisson d'avril demain.
En prétextant que dans certains pays il est 12H de moins qu'en France !
La première astuce c'est qu'un poisson d'avril ça se prépare, ça se scénarise un petit peu à l'avance.
Imaginez votre idée, écrivez la sur un bout de papier...
Un poisson d'avril ce n'est pas juste dire: "T'es moche...
Poisson d'avril !"
Ou: "Tu ressembles à Sylvain Durif... poisson d'avril !"
Vous pouvez projeter votre scénarisation comme un mentaliste, pour réussir ça.
La deuxième astuce, qui est plus importante encore.
Le poisson d'avril, dans l'idéal, vous ne l'annoncez pas vous même.
Si par exemple, vous voulez créer une situation, comme quoi vous avez gagné un truc complètement ouf, que vous avez eu un job de ouf...
Plutôt que de l'annoncer, vous pouvez créer un faux message sur votre répondeur par quelqu'un que vous mettez dans la combine,
et ce message répondeur, vous l'écouterez en haut parleur, devant la personne à piéger.
La personne que vous piégez, elle doit prendre connaissance de ce poisson là, mais d'une manière indirecte.
La troisième astuce, elle est reliée à ça.
Vous allez faire, ce qu'on appelle des convincers.
Ce sont des indices qui vont crédibiliser tout votre poisson.
Imaginons que je veux faire croire à quelqu'un que je suis enceinte.
Ouais, ça peut arriver, ouais on sait pas !
Je pourrais laisser trainer des tests de grossesses, avec un trait comme s'ils avaient fonctionnés.
Je ferrais semblant tout au long de la journée, d'avoir des nausées,
ou des envies, des envies de fraises, tout le temps.
De temps en temps je mettrai ma main sur mon ventre.
Je toucherai mon ventre, l'air perdu dans mes pensées...
Pour que tout soit cohérent !
Et pour vraiment ferrer l'hameçon au final, j'ouvrirai une lettre, que j'aurai fait moi-même sous Photoshop,
devant la personne, pour regarder les résultats de ma prise de sang qui dirait que je suis enceinte !
Et là, ce n'est plus un poisson, c'est une baleine d'avril !
En même temps si j'était enceinte, ça voudrait dire que je suis un hippocampe.
Donc moi on y croirait pas trop...
Ca m'emmène quand même à ma quatrième astuce,
que plus c'est énorme, plus on y croit.
Si demain je veux faire croire que je vais jouer à l'Olympia, ça c'est possible, c'est cohérent.
Si je l'annonce aujourd'hui en tout cas.
Alors que si je sors du domaine de ma réalité à moi pour créer mon poisson d'avril, là ce sera beaucoup plus crédible.
Crédible, parce qu'impossible !
Il faut aller au-delà de la farce.
Vers l'infini et au-delà !
Et donc cinquième astuce, qui rejoint un petit peu la deuxième.
Vous ne devez pas donner l'impression que vous cherchez à convaincre.
Si quelqu'un remet en question ce que vous êtes en train de vivre, et non pas d'annoncer. Vous le vivez, c'est un fait.
Si il y a une accusation comme quoi c'est une blague, vous ne relevez pas, vous dites: "Oui j'aimerai bien que ce soit une blague...!"
Parlez plus des conséquences de votre poisson, plutôt que d'essayer de justifier qu'il existe.
Et enfin la sixième astuce, pensez à l'avance au désamorçage.
Votre désamorçage, il doit être grand, il doit être somptueux, il doit être grandiose !
Il doit être à la même puissance que l'était votre poisson.
Imaginons, votre poisson c'est d'avoir un truc de ouf.
Un accessoire de chaque équipement de la gamme Apple.
A la finalité de tout ça, de toute cette journée, vous devez aller à un point relais pour aller chercher le colis par exemple,
vous y allez, vous revenez avec un gros carton, un gros coli.
Et la personne piégée quand elle ouvrira le carton elle découvrira dedans peut-être une boite de poisson pané, ou de e-poisson pané...
Ça aussi ça doit être une surprise !
Parce que c'est là où vous allez profiter du moment. C'est la révélation. Il n'y a pas plus beau que la révélation dans le poisson d'avril.
Mais est-ce qu'il y a un rapport entre ces 6 astuces et le mentalisme ?
Oui, je pense qu'il y a un vrai rapport.
Vous devez penser comme l'autre personne penserai pour pouvoir tout anticiper.
Vous devez analyser la manière de réfléchir de la personne que vous voulez piéger
et devenir elle dans votre tête.
Et en faisant ça, vous allez faire un poisson...
c'est une fricassée !
Merci d'être là, toujours de plus en plus nombreux.
Ca me fait extrêmement plaisir.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, ne faites pas du stop, mais mettez un pouce en l'air !
Continuez aussi à vous abonner en cliquant sur le petit logo qui a en haut.
Demain je fais un live pour avoir passé le nouveau pallier.
Je vous avez promis. On se fait le live des Mentalos. C'est un apéro live où chacun peut avoir sa menthe à l'eau.
Ce sera à 16H tout pile, et sur Périscope.
Pourquoi Périscope ? Parce que je n'ai pas encore trouvé tout le fonctionnement des lives sur YouTube et je ne veux pas reporter la date du live.
Portez vous bien et rendez-vous demain à 11H pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !